tell me about how important it is to be
able to have this life-saving equipment
at hand
okay it's a vitally important machine to
be able to use and speaking for my own
patient experience i i know how vital it
was that i had the best medical care
that helped me to survive a certain
cardiac arrest hence why i was working
with virgin media to
help the raises awareness because
they've got already 500
driver who already been trained to use
cpr they're also carrying a portable
defibrillator within the band with them
as well
okay so it's not just about the cpr is
it it's about the defibs as well and
people being confident enough to use
them because it's not hard but you do
think oh i'm not sure if i'm going to do
this right
yeah i i think it's important that once
you learn how to use it you have the
confidence to be able to do it you know
it's not about just doing you know to
have the defibrillator but also learning
how to do cpr
giving a patient and a
a huge percentage chance of surviving
instead of categories so as i said
earlier that every wrapping fund of a
500
500 drivers have been trained to do cpr
they're able to use it and they're able
to do the the manual what they need to
do in order for you to survive a certain
card occurs
okay so if somebody collapses in front
of you and you need to do cpr what are
the top tips that you would offer people
stay calm do the right thing
if you're trying to do to do it you know
what to do you need to do the basic lift
his head up if you're going to do the
the chest stuff you've got to make sure
you press as hard as you can don't mind
if you crack the rib as long as you keep
pressing and be able
to go nine and nine before you do
anything else just call 99 and start
doing the compressing stuff if you have
a defibrillator but use it as quickly as
you possibly saw
yeah i think it's it's to staying alive
isn't it it's that sort of um pace that
you need to do and it's it's quite hard
work you have to press down the rib cage
quite a long way as you said you need to
not worry about
cracking a rib because you can live with
a crack rib you can't live with a heart
that's been stopped sometimes it's
useful as well to have these
defibrillators nearby are they easy to
use
they they straightforward well i think
once you open the defibrillator it will
explain to you exactly where where to
put the pad on and i want to give a
shocker why not to give a shock a
straightforward okay
yeah and it actually talks to you
doesn't it so it basically tells you
whether a shock is needed or not so you
can't give people a shock if if it's if
it's not required so uh people should be
pretty confident about using those when
you see
i don't know things like happened to
christian erickson during the euros and
of course we saw a fan in the stands i
think in
newcastle the other day as well who
needed a defib in order to stay alive
does that take you back
to
the time around when you were poorly
yeah it's almost like um
i just showed that i'm very grateful
that on that day i had the you know the
best medical care that i could also wish
for and also they all came together work
under you know under pressure to be able
to get me from the pitch to the hospital
and also having access to a
defibrillator and good medical care as i
mentioned earlier it helped me to
you know made a a a decent recovery as
you can see in the summer that with
christian ericsson being able to the
captain of the national team coming in
to doing the cpr on him before the
medical staff do you know use a
defibrillator the newcastle fan you know
you've got a doctor next to him doing a
cpr on him before a defibrillator came
in so as you can see it's a vital skill
to have and will encourage adults to
learn how to do it and also have an
access to a defibrillator which is
always always helpful
what's life mean to you now given that
you were so close to losing it
i'm grateful i'm thankful i get to you
know enjoy spending time my family my
children
be able to do things that i you know
that
you know in if we speaking
if he's speaking the way we wanted to
speak i should not be here so for me
it's every single day it's you know just
enjoy it as much as you can
well you're looking incredibly well and
it's great to see thank you so much for
taking the time to join us thank you
thank you